- What's going on, Addy Hour fam,
just wanted to take a minute
to say thank you to all of you
who've been engaged,
who've been writing
with me on this podcast,
so to speak over the last year.
And for those of you who've jumped in
even after the year began,
just wanna take a minute to
thank you all since we are
actually at our one year anniversary
of launching the podcast
with our first episode
drop in March of 2021.
And it's been a great journey
to be on with all of you.
This is not the end by any sense,
we have lots of new episodes coming up.
I did wanna take a moment
just to acknowledge
all the support and
engagement and encouragement
that all of you listeners have
given over this past year.
Also for today's episode,
we're doing something
a little bit different.
The conversation is actually
going to be centered
on a new play, a new production
that's ongoing at the
Ensemble Studio of Theater
in New York City called What You Are Now.
And it really is a culmination
and a representation
of neuroscience meets the arts.
And this actual play has so many topics
that are at the heart of what
we talk about on this podcast.
So in this conversation today,
I'm honored to be able to
host the playwright Sam Chanse
as well as three cast
members from the production,
Pisay Pao, Robert Lee
Leng and Sonnie Brown.
It's a great conversation and with that,
let's just go ahead and jump in.
(upbeat music)
Well, welcome back to another
episode of the Addy Hour.
It's great to be here with
all of you and as always,
I've really enjoyed
hosting these conversations
and just having the opportunity
to peel back the layers
as we're on so many important topics
and to have so many different guests
from different walks of life
who've been able to share
their professional expertise
and their personal experiences as well.
It's been encouraging to hear how you all
as audience members and listeners
have really engaged in these topics.
And today I'm excited to be able to carry
that conversation forward again.
I had the opportunity to actually
see a preview of this play
a few weeks back,
and it's really powerful and
gripping story about memories,
about trauma, about resilience and hope.
Centers on the family
and the story of family
of Cambodian refugees
here in the United States
and their journey also leans
into the lead character
who's actually a neuroscientist
researching memory formation,
and also thinking about ways
that memory can be altered
and perhaps even removed
when thinking about the traumas
and challenges her family
has been through.
So today, again,
I'm honored to be able to be
able to host the playwright
and some of the cast members
for what I think will be a
really great conversation.
We're doing something a little
bit different because we have
four guests for the first time.
Usually we have three or less,
but I think this conversation
is one that's really gonna flow well
and also knowing the work
that they've done together
as a group, I'm really excited
to be able to host the conversation.
So to start out, I'd like
to introduce Sam Chanse,
who is the author of the play.
She is someone who has
been deeply involved
in lots of different types of work.
I promise her I'd keep
the introduction short,
not to go on too long about the accolades
so I'll leave it there for
now, but we'll also come back
some of her investment in
this topic as we go through.
But first thing I wanted to
actually pass it on to Sam
to introduce the cast members
who are here joining us today.
So Sam, I'll pass it over to you.
- Sure, so I'm just going
in order of the Zoom boxes
as they've appear on my screen.
Pisay Pao is here with us.
You're all in New York.
I'm in California right now,
but Pisay is playing the
role of Pia in the play.
Robert Lee Leng who plays
the role of the Ronnie
in the play and Sonnie Brown
who is playing the role of Shantrea.
- And Sam, I actually wanted
to start out with you.
As my listeners know,
I often like to check
in and see how people
are doing at this moment in time.
And with everything that we've
walked through in the last few years,
I know for the Ensemble Studio Theater,
this was the first production in a while
that was actually done in
person with a live audience.
So I just wanted to ask you
what that experience has been like
being back with the
production that you've written
in an in person setting,
how has that been over
these last few weeks
as the play has kicked on?
- I mean for me, it's been
really amazing to be in the...
To have had the time
in the room with folks.
And I wasn't there for
the whole process because
I'm in California right now
so I haven't been able to...
So I was joining on Zoom for a while,
which was familiar territory
after the last few years.
And I think it always
felt like this production
was very uncertain.
I think everything has felt really fragile
and I kind of didn't know...
I never really knew if
things were gonna proceed
from week to week, like
what was going to happen and
would this ever have an audience?
Would we ever be in the space together?
And so being in the space with everyone
and working together in this has been
it's just really beautiful.
And I think it really is uncertain also.
I feel aware of that.
Like, it feels like
everyone's been really putting
a lot out there to be
there and risking a lot
and after the last few
years, I think it just...
I think there's a
different kind of awareness
of the preciousness of
being together in space.
- That's really well said and
mirrors just a lot of things,
just I'm sure as you all have heard just
from so many folks too, that
have held those two together,
I mean, having that
precious beautiful moment,
but also the uncertainty
that's there at the same time.
So definitely appreciate how you
honestly shared that and
still true in a lot of ways.
The only thing I wanted to
ask just to get a feel from
the cast members as well,
how has that been for you
all being back onstage
and having people in the
audience actually listening in
and engaging with you and then also,
if you could actually just
talk about maybe a little bit
about your journey and what drew you
to this production as well.
I'd rather just ask
three questions in one,
but I'm gonna let you all take from there.
Actually, if we could start
with Pisay, that'd be great.
- Sure, I think I'm just sort
of still, what's the word...
What Sam just said really,
really touched me about the uncertainty.
I think that she just hits something
that's sort of been inside me
for the last couple of months
of working on this play,
the uncertainty of whether
this play was gonna go on.
We test every week so at
any point in the week,
we could be shut down,
whether we were going to have an audience.
This is my first time on stage
so the uncertainty there.
So the weight of that is
just sort of hitting me
at this very moment.
And it's really, really, I think,
closely tied to being a refugee,
the uncertainty that my parents felt
and the uncertainty that I
felt growing up in general.
And it's just all hitting me
right now at this very moment
cause of that one word that
Sam said, so thank you, Sam,
for sharing that.
I think that definitely
encapsulates my process
moving forward, but not certain
if we are going to actually go forward,
but still continuing
just like marching on because
damned if I'm gonna get on
stage and not know my lines.
So I don't know if that
answers all of your questions,
but that's definitely where
I am at this very moment
just having heard what Sam had to share.
- Thanks so much for sharing that
and just being in the moment too.
I mean, it sounds like a lot of it
is just kind of hitting
you in a way all at once
that it hadn't before.
Would you say that did
you kind of sense it
as you were walking through?
Or was it also cause...
I mean, at some level,
I assume you're also trying
to be about your craft
and about your work.
So you think it's something
that you just were focused
in the moment and at this
time have time to pause
or do you think you kind of sensed it
as you were moving
through that kinda feeling of uncertainty?
- I think I definitely sensed it,
but I'm reading this book right now called
the Body Keeps the Score.
And one of the main things about trauma
is that you don't have...
That most people can't verbalize it.
They can't put word to
what they're experiencing.
So I've definitely sensed it
throughout this whole process,
but I didn't realize
that what I was sensing
was uncertainty even though
I was feeling it sort of
all throughout because of
all the different factors
that we were talking about
with COVID, especially,
and with it being my
first experience so yes.
A thousand percent I sensed it.
And when Sam put a word to it,
it just sort of like binged.
- That's really well said.
Appreciate you sharing,
so honestly as well.
Sonnie what about you, how
has this process been for you?
- It's been an amazing process.
I remember one of the early
rehearsals asking our director,
Steve Kasum, is there a possibility
the show's not gonna go on
because we had the last surge
of COVID and it was
affecting a lot of people
and I was think, wow, okay.
So what's going, I mean,
are we here rehearsing for ourselves,
but even if we were just
rehearsing for ourselves,
the play hit me in such a
way that it was worth it,
because I've told Sam
this a couple of times,
and I tell everybody this is
the best role I've ever had.
Just in the complexity of the woman,
the things that she's gone through,
that people can find humor in her
and that she can break some
hearts is a dream role.
So I mean, it's amazing for me.
So the whole process has
been incredibly fulfilling,
but at the same time in the background,
there's all this stuff
going on in the world
and COVID is still a thing
and we're still getting tested.
We had a couple of scares,
but I mean, I personally
don't only speak for myself.
It's all been worth any kind of stress
or uncertainty for me personally,
it's just been a great journey.
- That's really powerful.
That's so great to hear.
I mean, in a sense as you're both sharing,
everything that you're
continuing to navigate,
even about your work
and putting this on for audiences as well
so definitely appreciate that
full spectrum of emotions
and feelings that have
kind of been going on
all at the same time.
Robert, what about you?
How's the process been?
- The process has been...
It's been a lot, it's been...
I think to kind of be
present in this moment
and hear what Sam, Pisay
and Sonnie are saying,
it is definitely highlighting
some of the emotions
and some of the struggles
that have stuck out the most, for sure.
And living within this
collective time of uncertainty,
definitely has been a lot of that.
And I think a lot of the days,
I've tried to be as fully
present and committed and kind of
try to put aside some of that.
Wanting things to be headed somewhere,
and there's been a weird
relationship with time.
I think my concept of time
has always been very strange,
like early on in rehearsals,
I would have this
feeling every day of like
we come here every day
and every day is new,
but then we're doing the
same things, and it's like,
this is how we choose to live our lives.
Like we come every day,
we commit and we put so much
hard work into doing this
with so many hours every day.
And I'm like, this is really beautiful,
but it's also such a...
I think it could be kind
of overlooked of like
you do this every day.
Like you commit your time on this planet
to doing this every day.
And I'm like, yeah,
like this is what we do.
And then with all of the uncertainty,
it just adds kind of like a weight to it,
an extra layer weight to it.
But overall it has been
amazing in so many ways
that I think are so many
things have been challenging,
challenging and painful,
and like pulling open of yourself,
but overall has been amazing
and I think it's such a...
Grateful to have this
experience so far, still going.
- Still going, still going.
Well, I appreciate that
level of candor too
as you all have been sharing,
just the process you all
have been going through
cause again, that's not
something I think people
wouldn't necessarily see at the front end
walking into the play,
but at the same time
as you all have been sharing,
some thoughts are coming to mind as well,
one because again,
there were so many aspects of the play
that you all pulled in together.
I mean, aspects of
memory, aspects of trauma,
racism, race relations, assimilation,
refugee status, family dynamics.
And obviously I'm biased
in watching it play too,
because I felt like all
the topics in the play were
all the things that were
about on this podcast as well
so it was really nice to
see that brought to life
in a sense,
but then even watching the preview
and this may have just been
me too, but I felt like
a lot of the emotions that
were in the play really kind of
left off the stage in a sense
and felt very real to me
in that moment.
And so I'm also just curious as you all,
cause you've touched on this already,
just your own life experiences
and how this has been
one of the most powerful
roles that you've been in
and how has your life
experience within this moment
and just in general impacted
how you've walked into the art in a sense.
And I'd actually just be curious to see
those emotions that I seemed the sense
that seemed so genuine to me,
was that completely you all
being just that excellent
in your craft or were
there aspects of yourselves
that also came into that as well?
So again, I'm asking lots
of questions at once,
but I'm just curious if you
all would want to comment
on any of those comments or aspects.
Robert, I might start with you
to kind of reverse the order
this time around, not
to put you on the spot.
- Just like how our life
has been our journey
leading up to this point,
like how it's kind of
like blended in together?
Just processing it myself.
I think it had to have happened like this.
At times, I do kind of think about
fate in a way and some things are
too much to be just coincidences.
And I think there's so many
things I don't understand,
but sometimes things
just kind of make sense
in some weird existential way
and I think that in terms of my life,
I feel like there's so
many stages in my life
where I just got completely lucky,
just without really being
able to understand it,
just feeling like I just got lucky somehow
and starting this process being here
and having these conversations
with all these great people, I'm like oh,
it seems like all that luck
kind of like contributes to
a purpose where I'm like, oh,
well then it kind of like
makes you look at things
and the past a little
differently of like, oh,
a lot of those things needed to happen
for this to be possible.
I think for me to allow myself to do this,
to see things in this way,
to try to work in this way,
to be giving and accepting
of a lot of these processes,
which are difficult.
And I think something quickly is that like
I think I lived a certain way where
somehow I continue to stay
really curious about things
and right now, like even in this moment,
throughout this rehearsal
play process is like...
I feel like as a man
walking through the world
slowly get into a place of like putting
a lot of those things down, which is hard,
but I feel like the more I put down
in terms of what it means to be a man
or what I've conceptualized in my mind
from a kid up until now is that like,
the more I let go, the more I put down,
the more I kind of like break down
and let kind of dissolve,
like the more I feel like
I can really be of service
and really be a part of something.
And I think I'm being vague,
but being around all of the great women
that I've had to a chance to talk to
and kind of trust and
just open up to has been
a gift in a very kind
of like personal way.
And I think living my life has been...
It feels almost a 180,
like I grew up at a time
where in my neighborhood,
the people I grew up with,
the ideology of people around me
was just so toxic, and
then just even living,
growing up in a Cambodia American family,
it's like there's so much
silence and there's so much
pain and violence and just
chaos like all the time.
And then it's like I feel lucky
that I was able to kind of like
maintain my myself somehow.
And this process is a continuation of that
I feel like if that makes sense.
Thank you.
- Of course and thanks for sharing too.
I mean, just that level
of openness as well,
and it may feel vague,
but also not vague in a lot of ways, too.
I think just understanding
what you're getting at and just
the great women you've
been able to be around.
It sounds like in this production as well,
and just the learning process has been
so thanks for sharing that,
definitely appreciate it.
Sonnie, what about what
about you in terms of...
I mean, you mentioned this
was one of the roles that you,
or the role that you've enjoyed the most
and how much of that has just
been from the character itself
and how much of that is from other...
What about this role really
brought you to that place
to say that?
- Well, she goes on a journey,
like a very profound,
serious journey of character
from a place of denial kind of,
of wanting to not share
the trauma in her life
to protect her children.
From that knowledge, I feel like at least
that's how I'm playing
her, because I feel like
you experience horrific things.
Everyone does, and there
are levels of trauma
that people go through
that can seem nothing to some one person,
but to that person, it is just as real
and me wanting to protect
the kids from that,
from knowing the horrors that I've seen,
cause I want them to live a normal life
that is without that.
But then it kind of starts to
come home for the character
where in a very real way,
like she's losing her grip on her family,
and they're going away
and not wanting to spend time with her
and I feel like in a desperate act,
she's like okay, I will try this,
give you what you are asking of me,
but it ends up freeing her too
in a way where she can
release toxicity inside of her
and be able to do things that
she thought were dead to her
all of these years.
I feel like that's a very real journey
that a lot of people go through.
Personally how I bring that to life,
we all actors have their
little secret bags and
you don't talk too much about them
because they are your secret things
and not everyone needs
to know where you mine
some of that gold from.
But in a very real way on stage,
I try to make it as like I
have two children on stage
and I love them deeply and I
would die for them if I had to.
And that's a very real feeling,
especially if you have a child,
you understand that in your soul.
If something were to happen,
you would easily gratefully
die for those children.
It's just something that's universal.
And so I can bring that
much of myself as a mother
to that role.
And then the rest of the trauma,
it's not that difficult
these days to be able to draw
on the horrors of the
war, and use some of that.
But I usually...
As things that I on to
prepare to go to a dark place
for two hours every day,
for six days a week,
or sometimes four hours,
depending on which day it is,
you have to go into a very
dark place in your head,
and I've been able to do it fairly quickly
where I don't have to
live there all day long
because that can be a very
difficult person to live with
for my family.
So yeah, it's honing the craft,
knowing how to access the
good and the bad in yourself
to try to bring it so
people can relate to it
in a very meaningful way.
But the core of it, for me,
all of this performance is all about love.
- And that comes through
so strongly as well.
So I think you were
definitely effective in that
and just the way you were
able to bring all those parts
of yourself into the character
cause that love definitely
came across as well
and just the journey that you were on
as the mother as well.
Thanks so much for sharing.
Pisay, come back to you as well,
cause again my comments about the emotion,
like I felt it throughout
and with all of the members
of the cast, but especially
with your character
in particular, like a
lot of that just felt
so honest and real, authentic
and raw all the same time.
So just curious how you were able
to hone the craft even as
Sonnie was talking about
so effectively in that space
and how much of that again
was from a personal place or even
just being that much in the craft
or any of those pieces in between.
- Thank you for that, I
appreciate you saying that.
When you first asked the question,
my stomach immediately started to churn.
I was like, oh my God, thank
God he's starting with Robert.
And then I was like oh, okay.
What does that mean?
When I first auditioned for it,
there's a scene and I was sort
of practicing with my partner
and we do a lot of that
especially nowadays
when everything is sort of done over Zoom
and he turned off the camera
and he was really concerned for me,
really concerned about the
words that I was saying and how
it felt so connected to
what my life has been
and what he knows of me.
And so my challenge has been,
because Pia is a different
human being for me
as much as I connect with her
on a lot of different levels,
my challenge was sort of really trying
to find that separation
and make sure that I
honor her as a character.
But of course there were things
that came in that couldn't be helped.
And then when those moments come,
the thing with live theater is
you gotta go with it, which
we've been doing with like
the cell phones going off
and the pipes going off.
And I think I find for me,
I find character through other people,
through real people and or
through movies that I've watched.
And in this case I was sharing with Sam
I have a relative who
reminds me so much of Pia.
She is talking about growing up and having
to run to her neighbor's house because
her parents were so scary.
But when she talks about,
it's just sort of like
as if she's sharing her
favorite ice cream shop
from when she was a kid,
it's not like it was super
traumatic for her and oh my God,
like save me.
It was just more like, oh
yeah, this is what happened.
So I drew a lot from that experience.
I have a friend who is an audiologist,
totally different from
being a neuroscientist,
but went through all the schooling.
And at one intersection of her life,
she did have to make a sacrifice
and not go to a particular school
in order to help her family.
And so I've been lucky enough
to draw from the community
that I have, and I was
telling Robert this too
when we first met, I was like,
I am not that kind of Cambodian
because I didn't grow up in a place
like little Massachusetts,
I didn't grow up in
Long Beach, California,
where there really is a very...
There's a bigger Cambodian
community and everyone's sort of
interacting and speaking with
one another and hanging out.
I grew up in a very,
mostly white neighborhood.
And so in some ways,
I was sort of ostracized
from my own community,
but no one, like obviously
no matter where I go,
if I meet another Khmer
person, so welcoming,
because our community
has been so separated.
So I feel really blessed to
be able to talk to my cousin
who I haven't spoken to in years,
or to talk to my girlfriend
also haven't spoken to in years
to feel that community
and that connection.
And then also the words on
the page are everything.
I don't have to do a ton
of work because everything
that Pia is saying and everything
the other character's saying,
it's just like how can you not feel.
When something's true,
when something's honest,
it's very, very hard to turn away from it.
And that also applies to Robert and Sonnie
and Emma and Kiran, who
came with such honesty.
It's how do you turn away
from your scene partner
when they're giving
you so much to play on.
I was really worried
about the very ending,
like if I could get emotional every night
and I'm like thank God for Sonnie,
because just looking at her
and seeing what she's going
through and telling her story,
and then listening to those words,
a combination of those things,
how can you not be so
moved by what this woman
has gone through and the bravery
of having lived through that
and raising two children
and then sharing it with her daughter.
So it was a combination of both things.
- Yeah, really well said.
And that authenticity definitely came out
throughout the production too.
I mean, even as I'm listening
to you all talk about it
and thinking back to the production and
having glimpses and flashbacks
isn't the best word to use,
but thinking about how you
all looked at each other
in certain moments, everything
you just said really...
I mean, I can think back
and see that and sense that,
I think that's part of what was giving me
that feeling as well as you all entered
into those spaces in a lot of ways.
So really appreciate, again,
the way that you all have gone
there in a brave way as well
cause even as Sonnie mentioned,
that's not a place that
you can stay all day long
for any number of reasons,
but just the way that you
all are able to even it out
and then as you all are talking,
I get a sense of community
amongst the cast members
and amongst the production
crew and everybody as well,
which I think also builds
into what you all are doing.
So again, just really grateful for the way
that you all have captured that
and are sharing that with audiences.
Sam, I did want to loop
back to you as well.
Again, as a person who has written this,
I'm gonna mention a quote
that I saw on your website
cause I really loved it the
way that you talked about
your work, exploring interactions
and collisions of race,
gender, science, and technology,
and centering characters
occupying some kind of marginal space.
You also mentioned that you
hope to contribute to efforts
to illuminate and elevate
marginalized voices.
I think that's just so powerful.
It's definitely the case
for me when I, again,
when I watch the production and
have seen that in your work.
But I also just wanted to
talk a little bit about...
Cause this authenticity
has really come out
in this conversation,
something I sense as well.
How have you been able to really craft
that sense of authenticity in your work
even as you're are elevating
some of these marginalized voices?
- Well, thanks for pointing
to that description.
I just wanna say that I write that
as a way to understand
what I do as an impulse.
I think that a lot of us do that,
I feel like a lot of us who are members,
who are in communities that are
marginalized and decentered,
not centered, naturally have that impulse.
I mean, it's just speaking
from our own truth
and telling the stories that we know,
which have not been
centered and haven't been...
And aren't widely recognized.
So I just guess I just
wanted to say too that
when I write that and it is trying
to describe what I think a lot
of us do naturally as artists
who are making theater,
like all of us on this call.
So I feel it's just
part of what the stories
that I'm drawn to and the stories
that are in me that I wanna give voice to,
or that I naturally give.
Those are the ones that just emerge
because they're part of the people
who have been part of my lives and my life
and the people who I
interact with and the stories
I identify with and in
terms of how I wouldn't...
I don't know how, I just know that
whenever I'm writing something
and this is true for this play,
it's always about how am I connecting?
Like I'm always connecting
with the characters
and the journey that they're on
and I wouldn't write it
if I wasn't identifying
strongly with them.
And I don't know how that will...
If that will resonate or not,
but there's a kind of gravity to the...
I feel that I'm drawn to certain material
and characters and stories.
And then maybe that's when I'm writing,
I'm writing from that
perspective and with this play,
I feel like I really
connected with the mother,
like with the parent and child
and the silences that are in the family.
I think that that's
something that a lot of us
have grown up with, and
I'm not Cambodian American.
My dad's Chinese, my mom
is Pennsylvania Dutch.
But there was something about the quality
of the silences and the
inability to connect
and the longing to connect
and all of the different
kinds of secrets and traumas
that are buried in families
and I think especially in...
Well, not especially,
but I know in a lot of immigrant families
and I just immediately felt this
belonging to understand your history,
your own history differently and feel
that maybe there are other possibilities
for what has already been written for you
or something that has
already been imposed on you,
but that if you could have some ability
to connect differently
with members of your family
and understand your
yourself in a different way
and somehow have...
I think there's a longing to do that,
that I had the longing
to do that with family
to be able to transform
relationships somehow.
- Understandable, but I mean,
that was so well said in a
lot of ways too cause I think,
again what you just brought
out in the character
is just that I dunno if
to call it discomfort,
but just that uncomfortable silence.
And I felt like you all as cast
members were just excellent
and pulling out what Sam
had written into that too
cause I find myself following
you all in that moment
and reacting with you and say, oh,
I wish this could come out here.
I wish this come out so it just, again,
felt so authentic and real,
I think in a lot of ways that people
would connect with that as well.
And then, I mean, to be completely honest,
also watching it as a neuroscientist
and that can be good and bad
because I'm thinking about,
well what's happening in
the brain at this moment.
Oh, I wish this learned behavior
could change here and this...
So, I mean, in a sense you all
pulled me along for the ride
in an authentic way that
was having me walk with you,
but also yearning for
things to be different,
thinking about what's
happening in the brain.
So on lots of different levels, again,
I think it was really
just important to have
those stories told in such
authentic and powerful ways,
but on that level of
authenticity as well and again,
this is something that's
not maybe as generalizable,
but again, just watching
as a neuroscientist,
I think a lot of scientists
from different fields
who might watch the play
will also be encouraged
to see how well you all integrated
some of those scientific concepts, again,
in a thoughtful and authentic way
that had real life application,
cause there's always that tension as well.
When Sam and I were talking,
one of the things we talked about as well
was just this tension
that sometimes comes up
within scientific communities
of promising new therapies
and new changes,
but then having that balance
of how realistic is this.
Is this something that we
can see in one to two years,
is this something five,
10, 20 years down the road?
And so again, from a
point of authenticity,
it was really nice for
me to see that interplay
and that tension also
play out in the production
as you all were talking
about memories and traumas
and whether those things
could be rewritten
and removed even, but then
also this tension of, well,
is this something that we
can only do in rats and mice
or does this actually have
applicability to humans as well?
So without going into the
weeds as a neuroscientist,
cause that that's a tendency
that could definitely
lean for us but I did wanted to mention
that that level of authenticity,
just in terms of bringing
that part to life
was something that
really struck me as well.
And then again, as a mental
health advocate, just again,
getting back to those awkward
or uncomfortable silences,
the ways that you've all highlighted that,
and that's probably that urge
I was having to kind of
push things forward as well,
just because, we've talked about that
in a lot of different communities,
even in African American
and black communities
and others immigrant communities,
as you all have mentioned them
also, the son of immigrants,
but the ways that those things
can be attention and sit.
So I'm wondering if any of you
would be willing to just share
what you've observed either
within Cambodian American
communities in terms of
these awkward sciences.
Are things moving forward
because in the play,
that was definitely something I took away
that you're trying to
move these things for
and that did happen in the
play in terms of talking about
some of the mental health
challenges and traumas,
but anything you all are
willing to share from
either your experiences or
observations in the communities
that you've been involved
in terms of mental health conversations.
- First I wanna say
I am not a member of the
Cambodian American community.
I am of Korean heritage,
but I was raised by the Browns
who are a very white couple
from upstate New York.
So I cannot speak to that question.
I can say that as an actress,
therapy is not a foreign island at all
because most actors are troubled enough
where they need to a
good amount of therapy
just to be able to access themselves
and know what's going on
in their emotional lives.
So like I understand the
benefit of being to go through
your own personal ghosts and horrors
and to bring it out as an
actress that actually...
I don't think it would be the idea
of erasing people's
memories I feel like is
a take away from that person.
Like Durani says in the play
that you change that person,
you don't wanna erase everything there
because it could affect them in a way
where they may not be recognizable.
And I believe that, even
though if it keeps you
from being able to live your life at all,
where you can't get outta bed
and you just wanna die
all the time, then yeah,
maybe it would have some sort of benefit,
but for most people, I feel
like you need your history,
but for the rest of the community,
I can't speak to that at all.
That would have to be Robert to say.
- I appreciate you sharing
that perspective as well.
I agree with you and then
we've talked about this
on the podcast, but the learning
that can happen from painful
and challenging situations
that you wouldn't want to
lose and remove as well
even though there still
are challenging people.
- I guess I'll say the
Cambodian American experience
in the community in my mind,
in my heart and also the
mental illness as its own thing
are very kind of interwoven
in my experience.
And that just is,
I don't know if it's good or bad
or there's so many
conversations to have with that,
but that's how it has been for me.
And Pisay is reading this book,
which I really love, like
when I first read that book,
it changed a lot of my ideas.
I saw things very differently after that.
And I think, man, I don't know,
I have very strong opinions I think
about when it comes to the conversations
that we have about mental health
and I think
we're definitely having
more conversations today,
but it's one of those
things that feels like
we're trying to unearth
more of like the realities
of how we have been having it before.
There's been so much
damage done I feel like,
and maybe I'm just so hyper
focused on those things,
but I've witnessed people
who are close to me
be heavily kind of like corralled
within that like big
pharmacy and the larger
kind of like confirmation
bias of what health is.
And we know that over time,
it's been revealed to
be a lot of fallacies
in terms of health in
general and mental health.
And sometimes I just get like...
I'm not sure if it's moving forward,
even though I ultimately faith wise,
I do believe that we are moving forward
with mental health and with the
Cambodian American community
in terms of how the two
things come together.
Faith wise, I do believe
we are going forward.
It just feels like it's one of those like
two steps forward, one step back.
And sometimes it's one step
forward, two steps back.
And I'm just like
ultimately I do think
we are going forward.
It's just really difficult.
I think again with these
marginalized communities
and also with topics that are
not generally widely at scale
had this challenges there,
so because it's important to me
that doesn't always mean
it's gonna be a point
to everyone else and it's like
there's a struggle there with
having that conversation,
but I'm grateful for this conversation
cause that's what we're talking about
and that's what's needed.
- That's really well said
and I'm with you on that
a hundred percent too
and some just thinking
as you're talking to
and this may be related,
but also a little bit stuff,
but just like you mentioned,
a lot of things moving forward,
but also moving back and the way
that things are sometimes
portrayed or talked about,
another thing that we've talked about
just on this podcast culturally,
like how are people actually
talking about mental health
and when we go to different communities,
are we centering that on
a white male experience?
Are we actually thinking about the culture
that people are coming from?
And that definitely
stood out in the play too
as you all were acting
out the different roles,
but like what understanding do people have
about other people's experience
that cultural competency?
So I don't know if that's
where you're heading,
but that's one thing that came to mind
as you were sharing too,
which I think makes things go
back and forth sometimes too,
because you can actually
end up making things worse
because you're approaching
it in one framework.
There's a real important topic to discuss
within mental health, but you approach it
from the wrong angle that
you actually do more harm
so I think those are really
important conversation.
And again, for me, it's
encouraging just to be all...
Robert, you mentioned to be
able to have this conversation
in this space to continue
to elevate those pieces
and to make sure that
things are done in a way
that's appropriate and that
there's room for learning
and that no one says they
have kind of all the answers
from one framework alone.
So as you can tell,
that definitely resonates with me as well.
Pisay, anything that you
want to add on that topic
as we're talking.
- A couple of things that
came to mind for me was like,
well I didn't wanna answer that
question because I was like,
well I don't want people
to think that my experience
is the Cambodian American experience.
So my parents really were
open to talking about it,
talked about it all the time.
I just didn't listen when I was a kid
or they talked about it in different ways.
It was like, you must
speak Cambodian at home.
You're not allowed to speak English
because we had so much erase
or you have to learn how
to do Cambodian ballet
or listen to Cambodian music
so it felt like it was very forced upon.
But then of course I hear people
whose parents never spoke about it.
I was talking to a mixed
Cambodian American friend
who didn't know who...
I said (speaking foreign language),
which is a translation
for the Khmer Rouge.
And he didn't know who that was
and I was like blown away
that he at least didn't know
what that word was
cause I heard it all the time growing up.
And then I remember hearing
about someone's relative
who was homeless because
they had some mental issues
and it shocked me.
It was like I can't imagine anybody
in the Cambodian community
being homeless because
we always take care of
our own, it was the idea.
So that's just all to say
that there is just such a
wide range of experiences.
And also based upon I'm
certain which wave you came in,
that was something that
was really new to me
when I started doing the
play is realizing, oh,
that's why some Cambodians
might be different from me
or others is depending on the wave.
So were you the first wave that got out
with the American troops escaping Cambodia
because you had the money or even prior?
Were you the second wave,
which I can't remember
quite when that was,
maybe that was right
when things were falling
and the third wave, which is
what my family went through,
being refugees, being in Thailand
after the country had fallen.
So I'm certain that your mental health
and experience is also based on that.
Another thing that came up
for me was my family and I
were blessed enough to go
back to Cambodia together.
I had gone there with just
my mom and then a friend
and then my brother who was
born in the camps with me
and my sister who was born in
America, we all went together.
So there are these like three
very different experiences,
but what really struck my brother
was how happy everyone was.
And he's a very happy person,
but he couldn't believe
you're going to a third world country.
There's people who don't have
nearly as much materialism
as you do, electricity,
running water and he was like,
people here are so happy.
It was what his experience was.
And then learning that there
isn't a word for depression.
I mean, I don't know the word.
Robert, if you know the word
for depression in Khmer,
I'm happy to hear it to be educated,
but there isn't even a word for that.
So how do you begin to have a
conversation about something
that, again, going back to
like verbalizing the thing
in which you're experiencing
is so important,
how do you begin to have that
discussion when you don't even
have a word for the thing
that you're supposed to
try to be verbalizing?
So not an easy answer.
- And I appreciate you highlighting
those complexities as well,
because it's not a monolith experience,
like you mentioned,
and just the different pieces
that you've even started
to see more and more over time,
which I know is gonna be helpful
for all of us to continue
to think about so I appreciate you.
And just sharing your experiences,
going back as well with your
family and your brother.
I mean, there's so many things
we could actually unpack there as well,
but definitely appreciate that.
- Yeah, of course.
- So if we start to wrap up
this time has gone quickly, Sam,
I want to loop back to you
and also just talk about
on here what you want audience
members to actually take
from the production as they're watching it
and experiencing it, and then
we'll ask the others as well.
- That's always a hard question.
I feel like everyone
comes to it so different
with their own set of experiences
and like different elements of the play
will resonate differently for everyone.
And I don't mean that to
not answer the question,
I just think that I don't have an idea
of like what I want
people to take from it.
I just hope that people connect with it
in some way that it illuminates
something for them or
allows that people can respond
and like feel some connection
with the material in a way
that you can take like reframe something
or it allows you to maybe
experience something
a little bit differently
or see something a little bit differently
or reinforce something.
I mean, even if someone
pushes back against something
very strongly and I think
that's engagement and for me,
it's about connecting with people
and whatever way people come to the story
and whatever way they connect with it is
how that person will connect.
So that's how I feel.
- Really well said.
That was a good answer to your question.
Not avoid it, but I think
that's really, really, really important
the way you phrased that.
Robert, what about you?
Maybe I should rephrase the question
so not necessarily that
people would take from it,
but while you're also hoping to...
Maybe just the hope that you have for us
as a society moving forward,
just either personally
or within the context of the production.
- I think my hopes have been very focused
throughout the entire
thing and still is now
is that it's very simple.
I'm only hoping that
Cambodian people see it
and can have a growing
sensation or a growing feeling
of their own selves, of
their own importance,
of their own place in the world.
And that has been kind
of like my only concern.
Like to be very honest,
I'm not really concerned with
anyone else seeing it at all.
And it's just like I get really...
I get really so many mixed emotions,
but I do get very happy
to think about someone
having that experience
and because I know some of
the experiences I've had
and the struggles I've had to
kind of like come into myself
and to allow myself to be like
this is something I deserve,
or this is something that is
like I'm worth this or that,
and if there's anyone out there
who has similar experiences
to me who feels that
way, I relate to that.
And I think it can be very important
for that person to have that experience,
to sit there and essentially
be talked about for two hours.
And eventually you start
to get that feeling,
is that like if I sit
a hundred people down
and I talk about you for two hours,
eventually you're gonna be like, oh,
maybe I'm important cause
people are like staying on it.
So that's my hope, that's my hope
and I don't know how far I can go.
I don't know all the different
ways that it can be received
or all the different
responses, but that is my hope.
- I appreciate that.
Being seen, being seen and elevated
in lots of different ways.
Thanks so much for sharing that.
And I can definitely tell
that passion's there too.
Sonnie, what about you?
- What I hope people take away from...
Well, I hope not just
Cambodian Americans see this.
I hope everyone sees
because I feel like there
are universal truths
being told in the show.
And so I feel like it can
resonate with a lot of people.
More than one mother has
come up to me and said,
I know that relationship
between mother and daughter.
I was like, cool.
That you can recognize that something
that we've brought to life on stage.
I would like people to
understand the truth
that's being told, that
America is not the big hero
that everyone wants them to believe.
We're a great country,
but we have flaws and we have
done some heinous things.
And I think shedding a light on that
cause a lot of people only know Vietnam.
A lot of people don't understand full pot,
and what happened in
Cambodia and that's something
that should be taught in history alongside
with a lot of other stuff.
A lot of people are trying to whitewash,
if that's the right word.
Right now, it's going on,
censoring is going on.
And I feel like it's important
now to tell the truths
of whether it puts you
in a bad light or not.
The truth is more important because
hopefully it will be repeated historically
like it is being done today.
So yeah, I feel like it's
important in that way
that everyone should see it.
- Really well said.
Pisay, I'm gonna give you the final word.
- Well, just to say,
I should definitely not
have the final word.
After this is all said and done
and people listen to the podcast,
I do hope that it encourages
people to do their own research
and come to their own conclusions
about things that they may
not have been familiar with
or things that interest them,
things that they may disagree
with, whatever it may be.
I just know that
when I get really interested in something,
I'll start Googling it,
I'll start looking it up.
So I think that's the important thing
is that we somehow peak
someone's interest out there.
My goal is twofold.
There's so much information in the play,
so much good information,
information that I didn't even know.
So any information that
people can take from the play,
whether it's related to science,
whether it's related to the brain
and relationships and fear memory,
or whether it's related
to Cambodian stories
cause that's also really,
really rich there too.
Sam did such a great job of incorporating
so many experiences and
ideas and histories.
So anything that people can take away
from that aspect and say, oh,
I didn't know that, I had no idea,
that makes me happy to hear my friends
or whoever come to the play and say,
I didn't realize that
because that's the seed.
And then the second thing is
having worked on Pia for so long,
researching different
aspects of neuroscience
and really thinking about
where she comes from
and her history and her story,
I can't help but feel
like a kinship towards her
and really wanna advocate
and be protective of the fact that
I hope people can walk
away understanding that
her blind spot was her love for her family
and her wanting a need
to have this connection.
She's a lot of like very angry
outbursts and a lot of...
She has a lot of things that maybe
didn't even make sense to me
sometimes so I think that,
I hope that parents and children walk away
sort of understanding like, oh,
is that something that I do
or have experienced myself?
I did have one friend who
couldn't speak after the play.
She was so emotional
about her own relationship
with her kids because she
had seen the relationship
that Pia and Shantrea had.
So in some ways, it's
like, yes, we did it.
But yeah, those are my two goals.
- That's great.
Well, again, I appreciate
what you all have done
in this production from
the writing to the acting
to so many different components and again,
just how you all engaged
in this conversation too
cause some of these
topics are emotional too.
I know we were entering in together
so I definitely appreciate
your willingness to do that.
And you can tell that this is something
that I've been really excited about
so I also appreciate your patience
with my five questions in the row
cause they're just kind of
all bubbling out at once.
But again, really grateful
for the production.
I hope folks,
this will be airing in
time for folks to still go
and see the production if they're able to.
And again, all the
things that you all share
just in terms of the impact
it's gonna have for Cambodians
and for society in general.
So, grateful for the time you
all have taken to talk here
on the podcast.
All the listeners will enjoy hearing this
and I imagine that people will
do some research afterwards
and even go back and
re-listen to the episode
cause there's so many nuggets
along the way as well.
So appreciate you all being here
and thanks so much for
joining the Addy Hour.
- Thank you Doctor.
- Thank you.
- Thanks so much.
(upbeat music)